i'm never busy oh yeah that might make
you flip friends oh geez guys have fun
you can prove to him what are you doing
Jean King really I feel like I'm gonna
kill you now terrible is gonna know its
Baltimore haha about things are
happening
I see ends up going oh sorry hi no they
get to fight another day
oh stop properly okay my aunt follow
this way oh why can you hide it should
we get out here oh gosh hahaha he was
open it what hello I think I mr. jumps
with it I miss scary big guys oh god
it's just she having a tough time open
the door was harmless is slowly oh but
don't leave me here with these behind me
we're talking yet just no one's
attacking yet where's the King oc1 hat
too
oh my [ __ ] what were they doing what
were the dreams that cause what it is
guilty you know what he was doing ok we
know what you would do it you're sick
you slowly back away we're gonna die we
gon get so many calories for this please
no I wanted to fight I wasn't like I
like they know I feel like they're just
gonna kill you now it's happening oh
it's happening I thought I cut as a job
behind me what I hate you that's what
I'm so I'm just going to do all this
right now I'm just wait okay okay hey
guy hey friend no what's up I'm Tony
bearing me this game because it's not
fair because I'm just coming can I get
for you know baby in there baby in there
to be in there with you oh wait oh ok
button right oh he's coming no he's
coming down there he says he won't
actually you can't
gosh Jen me shoot vikatan oh
oh yeah
yes
are you guys okay
so this serious jumpscare sure hope you
how that happen oh yeah pretty tablet
down my fellow